[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and today
was apple's wwdc 2017 and there's a lot
of stuff announced actually so for those
of you who don't want to sit through a
video of the entire three hour keynote
that we sat through this video is for
you so there were actually six main
announcements at wwdc this is a top five
so that means one of them didn't make
the list so tv os hope you don't mind
didn't make the top five but you know
it's better now it's refreshed it's got
a new ui it now supports amazon prime
video uh but yeah that's about it so it
didn't make the top five but now you
know about it alright so the number five
announcement is the new watch os four
for the apple watch now i'm not a big
smartwatch person and i don't wear a
smartwatch that often but if you do you
will notice that there are quite a few
little improvements to the apple watch
they added some watch faces so a
kaleidoscope watch face which is fun a
toy story couple of watch faces and also
now a siri watch face which shows a
bunch of new information and there's
some other minor stuff like being able
to send data back and forth between
compatible gym equipment and your watch
apple watch is a pretty popular fitness
watch so makes sense but all together
and all these little minor improvements
there wasn't really anything massive
that would make someone who wasn't
considering a smartwatch now think about
getting an apple watch it was more of a
bunch of improvements that would make
someone who already owned one and
stopped wearing it try it again maybe
stop collecting dust on a shelf on the
corner maybe it'll do that for me
actually i'll try it so number four is a
new version of mac os so the current
version we have on every mac the latest
version is mac os sierra the latest
version now which now has a new name is
called mac os
high sierra
that's
that's it there's no that's there's no
joke it's just that's the new name i
guess the reasoning is it's supposed to
be an improvement on sierra like a
perfection of all these little new
features that make it great so it's high
sierra i don't know just ignore the name
but again the id here is the same it's a
refinement it has a bunch of minor
improvements things like safari now auto
blocks those annoying autoplay video ads
it now also has intelligent ad tracking
prevention to help you stop seeing the
same ads over and over all over the web
it also now has a couple new filters in
the photos app there's a split view in
the mail app you know little things like
that the nerd in me loved the
announcement of h.265 support which is a
new video codec which will now also be
hardware accelerated and built into
final cut pro let's go and apple's now
gotten serious about supporting vr and
external gpus so for vr they're now
supporting the unity and unreal engines
natively in mac os and for external gpus
they're now focused on harnessing the
power of thunderbolt 3 and making that a
more viable solution for a lot of people
so there's now actually a developer kit
with a reference box external gpu
enclosure with a radeon pro graphics
card inside that you can buy from apple
i kind of want to get it either way
that's mac os high sierra that's the
real name public beta coming in late
june and then free upgrade for all mac
users coming in the fall now number
three
home pod now this is the announcement
that was probably the most hyped coming
into this event we knew like a tiny bit
of what might be shown but there's a
whole lot more that just got revealed
and it was a bit of a surprise so the
homepod is this this balloon sized like
toaster small toaster sized
hi-fi speaker
that also has some assistant features
built in on top side note i personally
don't think home pod is that good of an
idea for a name i would have gone with
something probably more like
apple home or
siri home or siri speakers or whatever
something like that but you know ipod
branding is so strong and it is a
speaker first so they went with homepod
so this thing has seven tweeters these
horns all the way around the
circumference around the base so
omnidirectional audio there and then a
four inch woofer firing upwards and
apple spent a lot of time hyping and
talking about how good this thing is
going to sound it is definitely a
premium hi-fi speaker first it's gonna
have some smart features that can detect
wherever you put it if it's near a wall
it'll know to bounce certain sounds off
of that wall and spread out certain
other sounds away from the wall it's
supposed to be an extremely smart
speaker and they spent a lot of time
with that on stage now you couldn't
really listen to it that well in the
demo area but i did get to listen to one
in a quiet area and i actually compared
it to an amazon alexa and a sonos
speaker and i can tell you for sure it
sounded a lot better than the amazon
alexa speaker and it sounded decently
better than the sonos too it has a lot
of bass obviously the smaller speakers
are lacking and plenty of highs too but
what struck me was the mids were
actually really full and rounded and
legible where they weren't in the sonos
obviously the alexa was not very good at
all so i gotta get one at home obviously
and listen to it with my own music and
my own sounds and figure out if it's
worth it in that category but assuming
the siri functionality on top of it
actually works well where you know you
can use voice controls to listen to
music and ask it questions about the
music and ask it for the weather and for
your calendar appointments and hopefully
it's gotten better since that comparison
i did with it versus google now assuming
all that stuff is true
then it looks like it'll be a pretty
decent product it's supposed to come out
for 349
in december so it's got some time before
that comes out and before it's actually
a finalized product but that gives it
time to get good and we'll be able to
see if it's actually worth that price
349 bucks sounds like a lot but when
compared to other high-end speakers
that's right in line and hopefully it
does more things and hopefully also by
december that gives us time to know what
we can do with it like right now they
advertise it as just like a siri and
apple music box but what if i don't use
siri app what if i use google and and
google play music or spotify or
soundcloud or any of those things will
work as just a bluetooth speaker i don't
know that's to be seen all right so
number two is ios 11 and this this got a
lot a lot of little features added to it
and then a surprisingly big visual
refresh they didn't even talk about it
that much but it's a lot flatter and
more colorful now but it's clean it's
clean so the new features include things
like imessage in icloud so now when you
switch between phones it'll also bring
all your imessages across you can apple
pay between people so now if you want to
pay someone who also has an iphone you
can use apple pay inside imessage to pay
them so that kind of makes it tough on
things like venmo and paypal if this
catches on there's h.265 video support
again and there's also now a high
efficiency image format which will
supposedly take a lot less space on your
phone with all the photos you take and
there's new image processing to make
better quality photos from the camera
and siri got a new voice it's a little
bit smoother and there's also a male
version too here's the forecast for the
next 10 days sunny sunny and sunny i
love machine learning especially since
i'm a machine learning and the control
center is redesigned now this definitely
looked a little bit odd to me at first
and i didn't like it right off the bat
but it's definitely going to take some
getting used to and i think this is one
of the things we're going to have to get
used to because ios control center right
now on the iphone is a little bit
finicky already so it looks to be an
improvement to that even if it's not
pretty it responds to 3d touch it's now
no longer paginated so all your controls
are your fingertips and it appears to
have more controls than you did before
so hopefully this is something that i
can get used to even though it's not the
prettiest thing there's also some
improvements to other first party apps
like apple photos and to apple maps it's
got things like lane guidance now which
is long overdue but why i really like
ios 11 and why it's so high on my list
at number two is because of what it did
for ipads for the longest time the
biggest weakness of ipads for me was for
how much they claimed to be able to
replace a pc and be a primary machine
for so many people
they could never really do even some of
the most basic things that pcs could do
at least in the multitasking and
productivity side of things they were
severely lacking but ios 11 on the ipad
now has for example a full-on dock like
the mac so a bunch of apps that you can
store down there
you have not only just the split screen
multitasking but you can copy and paste
things between them
you now have a full files app so you
have access to file system on the ipad
there's a new scanning feature in the
notes app where if you take notes with
the apple pencil it will actually be
able to scan that as text and recognize
all your handwriting and then be able to
archive and search through that with
spotlight which is amazing and craig on
stage went through all this stuff and
even more insanely fast i could barely
keep up i was scribbling it all down but
bottom line was it actually made me
reconsider how i think about the ipad as
possibly really being a first computer
or a primary device for a larger number
of people that's obviously going to be
its own full deep dive i have to get my
hands on the new ipad and that's
definitely going to be its own separate
video plus possibly the most underrated
announcement from all of today's stuff
and no one seems to be talking about it
as much as they should is that the new
ipads the new ipad pro came out you know
10 and a half inch display slightly
slimmer bezels but it has a display that
refreshes at 120 hertz
60 frames per second constant every
animation and you notice it i casually
dropped it on stage like oh it will
dynamically switch between refresh rates
you know lower refresh rates for slower
tasks like reading but also higher
refresh rates and you normally go up to
60 hertz on most displays but this will
be 120 hertz not just for gaming but for
like all the swiping through the ui and
swiping through pages and typing and
drawing with the apple pencil it's
extremely responsive it's like butter
it's like water like pulling your hand
across the ui it's hard for me to show
because this is all 30 frames per second
video but trust me when i say it's very
different and people should be pretty
excited about that so that takes us to
number one the highest profile new
announcement from today's wwdc which is
new max and the new imac pro so there
were hardware refreshes announced
throughout all of apple's lineup you got
new macbooks new macbook pros new imacs
there's now also a baseline 1399 4k imac
and a new baseline 1399 macbook pro
13-inch and all the imacs now have
brighter displays 500 nits standard
which is great now has fusion drives by
default which is meh but they also now
have the ssd option is faster and can go
up to two terabytes so i highly
recommend that and they're all running
kb lake intel chips on the latest gen
amd radeon pro graphics cards uh faster
ram more ram and they added two usb
type-c thunderbolt 3 ports on the back
of the new imax it's about time so now
it's looking like a real nice solid 2017
refresh and then out of nowhere out of
literally nowhere we got out of left
field this imac pro this all space grey
matte black
workstation grade
beast of an imac that i mean out of
nowhere up to 18 cores on the cpu side
workstation grade xeons amd vega gpus up
to 128 gigs of ram and then up to a four
terabyte ssd and 10 gigabit ethernet on
the back and four
usb type-c thunderbolt 3 ports
where did this come from it even comes
with a brand new exclusive space gray
apple wireless keyboard with the number
pad a space gray track pad and a dark
grey magic mouse all for this workhorse
of an imac with a 5k display so i got to
look at it i got to admire it i got to
even touch it obviously this thing has
my attention they even kept the sd card
slot on the back which is great it's
looking like a pretty robust suite of i
o for a pro user and the numbers and the
specs are making it look pretty damn
tempting for a pro user for someone who
uses final cut pro this seems like a
machine that would crush final cut pro
but the more i think about it it
actually seems like this is a really
elaborate trap
set by like johnny ive preying on
content creators whose mac pros are on
their last breaths this thing is going
to be starting at 5 000
in december so it's not like you can get
one right now you actually have to wait
a little time or pre-order and get one
in a couple months but if you think
about it who on earth is in the market
for a super high-end all-in-one with
workstation grade parts that's totally
not upgradable but as a total beast you
know you know see what i'm saying it's
two completely different things you
can't upgrade the ram cpu drives gpu any
of the things in this computer but it's
going to be an absolute monster people
who are buying multi-thousand dollar
workstation grade computers like this
don't buy imacs unless you paint them
space gray i don't know maybe i'm not
learning my lesson from the 2013
trashcan mac pro but i really want an
imac pro this thing looks absolutely
sick
and a lot of people from the photos i've
posted and reactions on twitter have
also been really into it too
but either way let me know what you
think are you into this imac pro or any
of the other announcements from wwdc
2017. i'm certainly interested to hear
your thoughts down in the comments
section below right below that like
button we're all talking about it all
day uh and that's where we're geeking
out down there so that's pretty much it
thank you for watching this recap video
hopefully it uh suffice your needs for
not watching a three hour keynote you
got all the info you need feel free to
share this info for anyone else who
might want to see it that's pretty much
it thanks for watching talk to you guys
the next one
peace
[Music]